doble pico de tensión entre el bloque
europeo y rusia este martes la corte
europea de derechos humanos comunicó las
conclusiones de la investigación sobre
la muerte por envenenamiento con
polonio-210 del ex agente ruso exiliado
en londres alexander litvinenko en 2006
el tribunal usó la investigación
británica como prueba y reprochó a rusia
no colaborar con información sobre sus
respectivas indagaciones
la corte concluye que a partir del
rechazo del gobierno ruso a aportar
documentación y de su falta de
refutación sobre la aparente implicación
del estado ruso en el caso que la corte
encuentra que el asesinato del señor
litvinenko es imputable a rusia
tanto las autoridades de moscú como los
implicados en el caso consideran que las
conclusiones del tribunal europeo están
motivadas políticamente contra rusia eso
empaña tomamos clases de por la
postura de la corte no nos parece clara
en tanto que decidió reflejar las
conclusiones claramente politizadas y
más que legalmente cuestionables de la
autoridad judicial nacional de uno de
los estados miembros del consejo europeo
el comunicado del tribunal europeo
coincidió con la revelación de un nuevo
progreso de la investigación británica
sobre otro caso de envenenamiento
la policía de reino unido señala un
tercer sospechoso ruso en el caso de
intento de homicidio del ex doble agente
serguéi skripal en 2018 en el que murió
un ciudadano británico por contacto
accidental con el agente venenoso
creemos que los tres sospechosos deben
ser puestos ante la justicia y quiero
señalar a la gente en rusia que está
detrás de esto que rusia ya pagó un alto
precio se desató la mayor expulsión de
diplomáticos en respuesta a los
envenenamientos de script a los rusos-
niega cualquier implicación y tacha las
acusaciones de propaganda anti rusa